are those caffeine pills at first
they're so exciting and then it gets
even more exciting but after that it
gets so scary and in the end you ruin
your girl group
shot at a recording contract what
watching save by the bell growing up i
always thought it was interesting that
they never really talk about
mario lopez or slater being mexican so
as a latina watching this it was so
refreshing to see the both of you sort
of take the lead
and save by the bell it was so so cool
but obviously you know you guys play
daisy and aisha um low-income students
transfer to bayside high school school
full of rich kids
how did the both of you balance you know
this really serious topic multiple
series topics like
with humor as well alicia why don't you
start
um it's an honor you know to be on this
show that
has such notoriety all over the world
and has had such a special place in
people's hearts
and then have us two latinas spearhead
it and
i think one of the best parts of our
show is that we're both
from the same culture but our own
distinct human beings we're these latina
women with our own separate interests
and goals and passions and
i think it really touches upon the fact
that the latinx community is not a
monolith
and we have our own views and we hope
that we empower people within our own
community but
as actors and performers it's been
so fun just exploring the juxtaposition
between having these very serious
conversations
um that need to be had and really
reflect the world we live in today
in addition to these moments that are
wacky and unconventional i think
it's one of the best parts of our show i
think it disarms people and
hopefully shows people that no matter
where you come from or where you look
like
these are things that you can care about
and conversations about equity and
representation and diversity are things
that
you should be discussing in your
household so it's awesome
yes i know we both started
i second that no i i seriously second
that i mean i i grew up
you know um not seeing a lot of
representation on tv
and i was always told that i can do
anything and be anything but i think
as a young latina it's always helpful in
a way to see someone that looks like you
that speaks like you
that has the same background as you
because you know there's times where
you may get down on yourself because
that's a real thing but to be able to
see someone being represented
in a certain light in a certain way in a
certain form
is so crucial to someone's um upbringing
and mindset and the way they take
information about themselves and how
they feel about themselves
so i love the fact that you not only
have one latina but you have two latinas
and two very different latinas but also
very similar in ways
um and and i get to rock some some curls
and
you know you see yeah it's good they did
a good job
no they really did honestly it was it
was so dope watching the both of you and
you know i'm not just going to reiterate
everything you guys just said but you
know alicia you mentioned the wacky and
the unconventional that's what we loved
about saved by the bell a lot of this
stuff
i remember watching in the show saturday
morning eating cereal i'm like this
doesn't make any sense
what was it like for the both of you
because we what's cool is that in this
reimagining of the show
we still get those wacky unconventional
moments so what was it like for the both
of you to sort of be the only rational
people
at bayside high school it's scary why
don't you take this one
i feel like i'm always rational almost
in
my outside life as as or hopefully i
hope i am rational um
but being able to see that rationality i
think uh
plays very well because then you really
see
the difference between the douglas kids
and the bayside kids and what separates
them
and how different they are in their
thought process
and you kind of get to see that play off
on how each character
kind of rubs off on each other you know
i get a lot of
lexi and a lot of max kind of way of
doing things it's like
not being able to take charge and not
being able to
uh enter a room and feel like i'm taking
up too much space because that's
how how what they do and i'm like you
know what i'm gonna do that same thing
and then on the other side i feel like
for their characters it's like oh wow
you know daisy is
passionate and she sees things
differently and she has a voice
not only for herself but for everyone
surrounding her maybe i need to take a
step back and
and see that for myself and kind of take
that on
as a as a trait and as a characteristic
so
we get to see that too because your
character breaks a fourth ball which i
think is really awesome that they hang
through um daisy's eyes saved by the
bell is one of the best things
shows to come out of the 90s i love the
90s i'm rocking time
what do you think is your favorite 90s
trend i always say high waisted jeans
highways props crop tops i own a lot of
crop tops i don't think i own
a regular sized t-shirt i need to go
shopping
actually a fact yeah right every day i
said did i not have a crop
anywhere but you look phenomenal in all
your crop tops so keep wearing your crop
top
um specifically for me i am in love with
the 90s culture but i think something
really cool about our new show is that
i as aisha wear a lot of 90s fashion
more reminiscent of the 90s hip-hop
culture which we don't really see
in the original save by the bell so
you'll see aisha wearing like really big
uh similar to like tlc overalls and
door knockers so she definitely honors
the 90s in her fashion
in this new cool reinvented way
can we talk did you just sit backwards
in a chair wow i've never seen anyone do
that in real life i
am so stoked to talk to you guys my
first question is for you belmont
because you play jesse's son
but you're sort of like the slater in
this show so i was curious
you got a chance to sit down with mario
lopez or elizabeth berkeley and talk to
them about your character and
and what you wanted to bring to jamie
yeah absolutely i remember
um well i met elizabeth during the
audition process and then
when we were shooting the pilot in that
first week um i had wrapped kind of
around the middle of the day and
elizabeth was on set
um just as a producer and we were
sitting in video village where there was
everybody watching the monitors
and and then it was somehow hours later
and we were just
two people sitting in chairs in this
empty space having this wonderful
conversation
talking about um how the dynamic is in
the family and
the relationship between the two of them
and yes uh
jamie and mario have some similarities
as well
um so i got kind of got to dive into
those similarities with him
and just meeting both of those original
cast members and working with them
uh has been an absolute blessing it is
very cool experience
what from mario slater did you want to
bring in and jamie specifically
well there's like this uh competitive
jockey sports aspect to slater that
jamie
totally has the only difference is
slater's genuinely athletic and
jamie is clueless
and dexter you actually got to shoot
with mario
solo i got to see in a couple of
episodes so tell me what that
was like and do you have any fun stories
from set shooting with him specifically
that you can do yeah of course i mean
um you know when when i got the role and
i found out that the majority of my
scenes were going to be with him and the
pilot
um it definitely just brought me a
little ounce of nervousness if i'm being
100 transparent with you
but excitement as well and then of
course meeting mario and chatting with
him and he gives you that smile
and brings you in for that handshake and
hug it makes everything go much more
easy
and it allows you the opportunity in the
space to be able to create something
really really beautiful and special
you know mario and i have so many mutual
interests from
dance from being pop culture nerds of
the 80s and the 90s and
and so you know we were always dancing
around on the set and trailers and
shooting instagram videos and his
daughter is very big on tick tock
and so so whenever she was around we
would be making up some tick tock dances
and stuff like that so mario
and elizabeth both all actually all
every single og that we brought back
really made it a point to just sew into
us
and let us know that you know hey we
know we were the first but you guys are
the now
and we appreciate you and we support you
and so having that really was was really
fantastic
that's a really nice sentiment
especially because your character
devonte
i hope i'm saying it right because it
was funny yeah and like how you
pronounce my name in the show
whoever's watching this when you watch
the show that'll make sense but um i
wanted to ask
both of you is there any did you go back
and watch
you know the original and it it's kind
of fun to poke fun at sort of the
corniness
and the cheapness from that show so what
was
easy for you guys to naturally you know
poke fun at this time around from from
the original
it is fun tracy um wakefield our
showrunner did such a phenomenal job of
towing that line between being
self-aware about the corniness of the
original show
and then still honoring the beautiful
aspects of the original that everybody
loves
really just walking that tightrope tracy
did a phenomenal job and so
it was very fun the humor is a little
different just like
the show is different because it's newer
um but i'm excited about um
all the jokes yeah growing up such a big
fan of the original show
um you know like i i loved zach kelly
screech slater
lisa you know jesse like i love them
growing up but i do also understand
that say by the bell in the 90s does not
work fine does not work in 2020.
so um i think like like belmont said so
beautifully tracy and our producer
franco who was a part of the original
series
found a really really great way to
combine the
the the nuance and the nostalgic aspect
of the original show
with the groundedness and the reality of
the world that we live in today
and i hope that it continues to be
transfer like translated that way and
understood that way
what is your favorite thing to come out
of the 90s
favorite 90s trends oh the jordan won
the jordan one the high top jordan one
it could be the og
all the different color already
alliterations i'm a sneak ahead
i love sneakers and so um and now my
accent just immediately comes
ahead actually i just immediately get
right back to my
south jersey seas but um yeah the jordan
ones is probably the best thing
to come out of the 90s for myself for me
it's got to be the music i love
all i still most of the music i listen
to comes from the 90s
rem weezer the police all that good
stuff
but yeah i'm a sneak ahead too
you only know how bayside works for kids
like you hot kids
privileged kids privileged kids oh my
god lexi your character is just
everything serving books best one-liners
she's
transgender we so rarely get that type
of representation in the tv space let
alone the high school tv space
so i first wanted to ask you what was it
like and how did you feel bringing
being able to bring lexi to life with
that in mind
i mean she is literally the most fun
character i've probably ever played
getting to wear
six inch heels to algebra two in the
morning is
an experience i never thought i would
live through
she's so fun and there's so much to her
that i think is so interesting and
entertaining to watch throughout her
experience on the show and her arc
as a human being i think you see evolve
throughout the season
and i think that's really topical for so
many people in america right now
having this kind of reckoning where
they're realizing their privileged
bubble isn't everything and
i really love that about her and the
other b-side kids arc
in the show what did it mean to you to
be able to bring
you know a transgender character to life
in sort of this space because we so
rarely get that representation
yeah it meant everything to me i think
when tracy had he came to me um
about wanting to do uh the show it
wasn't
originally planned for her to be
transgender
but the more we talked about it the more
we saw an opportunity to
have representation like this on screen
because so often trans representation as
we know
usually has to do with the trans
struggle or
puts trans people in a negative light in
a negative experience so
getting to tell a story and serve as a
producer on a show where i had input
on making sure it was authentic as
possible was the greatest opportunity
ever because
i think with me and tracy coming
together in our writers
we really told a story that isn't all
about her gender
and it's so much more than just her
gender but does
tackle that part of her which i think is
really really important
so incredible and so needed and can't
wait to see so many more and you kill it
and i saw your also you know producer on
the show so congratulations for that
it's amazing
yeah obviously you know lexi's this
she's awesome she's this
cheerleader most popular popular girl in
school we've seen this archetype before
so
who are your main influences for lexi
like did you go back and watch like
regina george clips like
who was your main influence my biggest
influence
uh for lexi was the dreams that i had
growing up as a young child only wishing
i could dress
talk act half the way lexi does
so that was my full on uh sort of
i would say inspiration for the
character but the more i did it the more
i found myself um talking a lot like
catherine o'hara in shit's creek i've
literally said this in every interview i
i guess what i'm saying here is i'm
obsessed with catherine o'hara and
schizophrenia
i wish i was her um and i'm sad that i'm
not uh
but i just found myself like speaking
in weird dialects uh in the same vein
that
katherine does in that wonderful show so
yeah i'd say a mixture of her and um
of just my dreams that's honestly iconic
moira rose is literally my favorite
character and i'm happy you said that
because i wanted to ask
where you got lexi's mannerisms and and
just the way she moves their hands i
wasn't sure if it was just how you
are or but yeah watching shit's creek
like i notice you sort of whisper your
last line
you know when you're saying things like
you'll you'll sort of lower your voice
so i wanted to know where all that came
from did that come from mueller rose
yeah i mean there were certain things
that came from her but also just me in
my regular life people that know me know
that i'm
an insane human being like i have
moments where i can be a humble child
that speaks normally but i also have
moments
where i am a person from mars and i'm
not making any sense
um but what i thought was actually
really funny is throughout the show i
like wanted to find new ways of holding
like my little handbags
and i saw that the girl who played
alexis on shit's creek like
had the same sort of idea of like
finding new ways to do it so she did
like
the pretend handbag thing and my thing
was holding
a handbag with just one finger and
you'll see i believe it's an episode
seven
where i have this tiny purse that is
literally big enough for an edamame pee
and like that's it maybe like half of a
lip gloss too
and throughout the entire episode i hold
it with a single finger so that'll be
fun for people
wait that is so amazing that was like my
dream answer because i i've done a lot
of research on how alexis took this and
made it this yeah
so i just want to ask you one last
question what is the best thing to come
out of the 90s for you
the best thing to come out of the 90s
for me
is probably the fashion the low rise
jean moment the messy
dirty girl hair moment um
and the spice lip i think we need to
bring it back she deserves to be
researched so
those things i would say my dad's also
coming i don't care about your dad
spencer i just care about
zach and kelly hello john should i call
you john or michael i know i don't i
feel like you go by michael right
i do go by michael i most people don't
know that but
yeah if you want to get my if a safe is
about to fall in my head
say michael because i'll move if he's
coming i have to think for a minute i
was like oh i'm john
so michael there's a thief coming
amazing
i have waited a very long time to
interview you your career
is just so varied you've played so many
different characters what was it like
coming into the role of principal todman
and playing a high school principal
uh you know it's not the first high
school principle i've ever played i
think i've played about 94 of them
and it's it's one of the things i
i do a lot anything that works with a
tie that's what i do
uh but um i
i actually love this show i've really
i've become very attached to this show
and i think i think part of it is that
my colleagues are so um young
and talented and i sort of am reminded
of when i was a young actor and
and how i engaged with the work and how
i was changed by it and things like that
and
and you know i've been doing it so long
now that you you do forget these things
and they're very important
you know and um i have just been sort of
enlivened by this job strange
i really have because i'm one of the
only you know like there's just a few
adults in the cast you know and it's
it's really thrilling to work with
that much collagen frankly
[Music]
michael you are hilarious yeah no true
being around someone you know that's
doing something for the first time
is very exciting and it is to hear you
say that it livened it up it
you know it sort of warms my heart to
hear you say that that's really cool
you've played so many principles but
obviously this is a reboot so
did you channel mr belding at all or
reference his performance for
for todman uh well yeah we'd like to say
uh that the show is a reimagining not so
much a reboot because there are so many
new characters
really uh mario's character and
elizabeth berkley's character are the
only
characters that are in the regular cast
that are returning from
from the old show from the 90s i'm a
totally different person
than uh dennis haskins played i have a
different name i have a different you
know
set of problems i have a different
personal life so i don't really do
i didn't need to do research there what
was useful for me is to watch a couple
of the old episodes and watch out dennis
askins
uh negotiates his performance amongst
the kids
because it's it's tricky uh the the
sweet spot of the show is watching these
kids be
a group and friends and see what issues
they have
and then this sort of referee this adult
referee is walking around mostly to be
pranked and to be
you know demeaned in some way because
he's he's the heavy
but also to sort of facilitate what
they're doing and sort of pull comedy
out of them
so uh that that was very useful to to to
watch dennis do that and he's
superb at the same time there's also a
lot of you in this character you know i
know you've come from
broadway michael you've written vocal
arrangements for things you've been in i
don't want to give too much away but
obviously principal todman does have
like
a musical tie in the show or people
would we'll see once they watch it so
how did that come about was that your
idea
well i think you know um tracy whitfield
who's our
creator on this show and our writer um
she and i have a relationship she and i
did a show together called great news on
nbc a couple years ago and you know
so she once she gets to know a person
me in particular in this case uh she can
write toward me
you know and so a lot she knows that i'm
musical and she knows that
i do x well or why well and she will go
ahead and write it in
because she likes to see me do it and
she also unfortunately
uh knows what hurts for me
so she will make she will demean me
very often in the writing me personally
michael
so that you know she knows she she knows
that
i will be embarrassed by some of the
things that i have to
say she knows how to get me so it's
really
it's been a pleasure i'm shocked to even
hear you say that you've been
embarrassed because just
some of the stuff that you've done is so
i after one martini i turn into richard
from the breakup
you know how many times have you been
asked to do that in real life
oh my gosh boy you hit it on the nose i
tell you
i now's i can't go into a grocery store
without somebody you know pointing
across the
you know the coffee aisle and saying
like there's
there's gary on the kick drum there you
know what i mean it happens all the time
it's every day almost yeah just that one
scene
you know you never know you never know
you do a scene i didn't even remember it
and you know years later it's like i
have to deal with it every day
it's crazy
[Music]
you